adesso il momento un momento molto
particolare il momento della poesia Voi
penserete con la poesia abbassiamo il
ritmo un pochettino invece probabilmente
non è così perché
altedex di Policoro secondo ospite di
intrattenimento della serata arriva
Giuliano logos campione del mondo di
Poetry Slam un applauso
ho cercato la sorgente così tanto
che oramai mi disse dava solo il
pensiero
non era il viaggio oggi l'intanto ma il
bersaglio Il miraggio il traguardo che
ho posto a fine sentiero ed ho lasciato
pezzi di me stesso indietro perché il
peso di tenere i mondi addosso Io ci ho
provato ma vi giuro che non lo retto
ed ho finito per poi trascinarmi i miei
rami potati sul petto come medaglie ad
un valore che ho perso come stelle
polari Nel pezzo di cielo di un eso
pianeta più freddo adesso sono in piedi
sull'orlo del baratro e guardo giù e ne
ho il terrore e non perché ho intagliato
coi rami potati le ali di un Albatro e
la cera e le piume si sciolgono al sole
No in fondo se mischiando se vado al
suolo mi costruisco Ali più grandi e
riprovo Lo faccio da sempre ma se
andando in alto poi invece rimango in
volo e lì non ho piani né muscoli alibi
numeri argini punti Ali più utili niente
e continua a darmi la colpa da solo come
incolpando i fratelli Wright per
l'attentato al World Trade Center Io
volevo solo volare Volevo solo volare ed
ero disposto a volare o schiantarmi
non ad accettarne le conseguenze
Ciao
io sono Giuliano Logos
quello che avete sentito È un esempio di
poesia performativa io volevo aprire con
questo per due motivi uno perché questo
testo per me parla di vertigine Nel caso
specifico vertigine di fronte alle
conseguenze delle proprie scelte secondo
motivo è che è stato scritto ormai quasi
una decina d'anni fa in uno dei momenti
più bui della mia vita profonda
difficoltà a causa delle pressioni che
sentivo in quel momento ero ancora uno
studente della facoltà di giurisprudenza
dell'Università degli Studi di Bari Aldo
Moro
sembra surreale lo sento e
contemporaneamente sentivo la pressione
delle decisioni che mi erano state
imposte o che avevo deciso io di imporre
me stesso nella misura in cui siamo
all'interno di un sistema che Ci obbliga
alle eccellenze chiaramente questo si
ripercuote su quello che poi tu vai a
fare ed essere nella vita io nello
specifico Non sapevo quale fosse la mia
direzione quindi certe felici di sapere
che dopo una laurea in giurisprudenza un
master in relazione internazionale uno
in comunicazione di impresa relazioni
istituzionali adesso di lavoro faccio il
poeta
questo ci dice
forse che le strade non sono così
definite come sempre ci dicono che sono
e questo mi ha fatto pensare che
nonostante mi abbiano sempre detto che a
un certo punto trovi la tua direzione e
poi quando la trovi sai che quella è la
tua direzione per alcuni non avere
un'unica strada definita un'unica
direzione Ecco forse per alcuni è la
propria direzione cambiare strada è la
strada per alcune persone Io non lo so
se vale per tutti o vale per alcune
persone però so che ho sentito questo
profonda difficoltà e ho immaginato di
scrivere altre persone che l'hanno
vissuta e la vivono allo stesso modo per
dire che non esiste un'unica strada per
forza per tutti e sul tema ho pensato di
poter dire che a me non c'è niente che
spaventi come un percorso dritto
prestabilito è finito rivolto al
tramonto rivolto al declino rivolto al
delirio di credere che vi sia vita nel
monocorde ripetersi delle Ro taie su
quell'unico binario rettilineo che parte
nel giorno in cui nasci E declina i tuoi
giorni gli uni più identici agli altri
fin quando c'è quello nel quale ti
accorgi che i capolinea Ormai è troppo
vicino e non hai più scambi o stazioni
davanti ma solo il metallico medesimo
mortale ripetersi di altri giorni uguali
al primo senza il Sacro ancestrale
profondo ruggito
del Bivio
dio dei crocevia
delle scelte che tagliano in due i mondi
possibili delle ramificazioni di vita su
muri di edere dei limiti fisici di
questo mio corpo di fibre e di cellule
Lasciami il tempo la forza la voglia il
coraggio ed il modo di scegliere io ti
prego Non farmi trascinare su questo
filo perpetuo di inutili coazioni a
ripetere Regalami vite di labirinti di
esche di cui si esce di scale riesce di
crescita di cedimenti di perdite di
giacimenti di cerchi concentrici di
gesti di gentilezza incoerenti e
randomici Diego solo forse esterne di
lucciole per lanterne di lupi per
libellule di dirupi dirupi di ruggine di
tributi di urli di fulmine di tiurne
notturne ed eterne contuse confuse e
confuse risate anche non spensierate
purché siano vive
Purché sia vivo
Purché sia io a scegliere
Dio di crocevia protegge questo viaggio
da ogni sabbia corrente sbriglia i venti
striglia giumenta e notturne di incubi
se devi mettimi pure alle costole ogni
demone che riterrai necessario se questo
serve a rendermi forte ammettermi a
correre a rendermi fiamma prima che
Carbone tizzone ardente prima che
Giungano Moire a rendermi cenere dio dei
Crocevia So che non puoi darmi certezza
perché se la rotta fosse corretta
perderesti ogni senso di essere e di
essere io ti chiedo soltanto di essere
di essere Ti chiedo soltanto di essere
felice
nel grande mentre nel grande quadro nel
grande quando mi verranno a prendere e
se questo deve portare il mio corpo
attraverso uragani e tempeste che sia
tempesta ad ogni via Dio di crocevia Dio
delle scelte di tutto ciò che potevamo e
vi giuro possiamo ancora essere Aiutami
a questionare ogni passo non ti chiedo
nient'altro Rendimi destinato ad essere
libero da ciò che Sono destinato ad
essere
per quello che vale te ne sarò
Eternamente grato e per questo Amen out
tamquam non esset
Grazie
[Musica]
nella misura in cui le decisioni che
prendiamo e le strade che abbandoniamo
rimangono con noi perché poi alla fine
delle poesie mi trovo comunque a
scrivere out tamquam non esset che in
giuridiche significa e così non sia che
il contrario di Amen e immaginava che un
Dio di crocevia potesse per forza avere
una biforcazione alla fine della poesia
quindi questo questo spettro Uniba mi è
rimasto addosso ma la poesia
performativa che ho incontrato anche
grazie alla lips la Lega Italiana poi
trislam che è un'organizzazione
Nazionale che organizza delle gare delle
Battle di poesia i cui vincitori poi si
sfidano a livello addirittura
internazionale A livello mondiale ecco
aver scoperto questa realtà che peraltro
ha tra i fondatori una persona che è
presente qui questa sera che Francesco
Fittipaldi che è di Policoro
ed è un uomo che ha fondato nel 2013
questa Lega Italiana Poetry Slam Ecco
aver scoperto la poesia performativa mi
ha dato degli strumenti per conoscere me
stesso e per raccontarmi e raccontare
parte della mia vita e parte del
territorio da cui vengo in particolare
Mi piace l'idea di trasformare la
bellezza che vedo in parole e provare a
raccontarla ci sono molti genitori che
raccontano le favole ai propri figli mio
padre non mi raccontava le favole mi
raccontava le storie di Federico II di
Svevia giovines staufen questa cosa ha
avuto chiaramente un impatto sulla mia
psiche Come poter immaginare Ho provato
a mettere in parole la vita di una
persona incredibile come Federico II di
Svevia che tra le tantissime cose che ha
fatto ha anche contribuito alla nascita
della scuola poetica siciliana da cui
poi è nata la scuola poetica Fiorentina
da cui poi è nato l'italiano che
parliamo oggi quindi se parliamo queste
parole e grazie anche a questa persona
che ha fatto tantissime altre cose che
ho provato a riassumere se è possibile
un testo che racconta la vita neanche
soltanto di di un imperatore che
chiaramente è cresciuto nel sud Italia e
Oltre chiaramente essere nato a Jesi ma
è cresciuto nel sud Italia prima in
Sicilia e poi chiaramente come ben
sappiamo aveva molto a cuore tutto il
Meridione Lo chiamavano addirittura Pooh
era Puglia e figlio della Puglia Quindi
lo sento particolarmente vicino a me ma
quando questo messo papale arriva in
questa Antica Palermo e vede questo
ragazzino che secondo la leggenda gioca
nel fango ho immaginato che chiaramente
questo senso di sconvolgimento nei
confronti della vita si potesse
racchiudere in questa visione
il sole
è un incudine d'oro
e tutto è schiacciato e trafitto
e al Cantico fulvo dell'astro fai coi
cromatico giubilo ogni chiesa tra 0
minareto e terrazzo nei doni del giallo
del rosso e dell'indaco
esplodono aranceti e le palme e di
peschi e le mandorle
del Borgo
la al limitare del Borgo
esplodonoranceti e le palme a limitare
del Borgo nei colori del vivido caldo
quasi di liquido magma nel Limpido
Maggio di calma del 1204 Palermo a
paglia Federico avrebbe 10 anni e
Palermo abbaia e splende di luce araba
di voce Normanna del canto libero del re
bambino dal volto Germanico dal verbo
Siculo e sangue vichingo che urla in
strada dimentico del Papa dei timore di
Innocenzo III della reggenza spaccata
del mondo cattolico al centro il tempo è
un arco e lui lo tende dilatandolo tra
il canto di un imami il bazare un salmo
con la stessa Grazia dello spazio che
distanza le ali del Falco da caccia che
ama la sua vita è in piazza è nato in
piazza e vive la gente in piazza come
avrebbe voluto sua madre Costanza
d'Altavilla lontano dagli intrighi di
Gualtieri di pale aria ma oltre Scilla
il mondo attende ancora di vederne il
valore e la Germania quasi
in mano a Ottone di portare il blasone
del suo colore e sentire risuonare in
ogni Androne il nome o Einstein
E allora cinta la corona con quella
d'Aragona cambia dimora e parte oltre il
destino ultralpe come faranno ancora per
secoli i giovani di queste lande non ha
la discromia oculare di Alessandro Del
grande ma del macedone ammira
l'ambizione non è cavalca lo stesso
elefante di zanne d'Avorio ma ne porta
lo stesso ardore nell'occhio un fuoco
come un incantatore dinanzi al grimorio
mentre in ginocchio il labbro da uno
schiocco secco l'anello pescatorio e
papà Onorio III lo proclama Imperatore
quelle cose di cui ti penti e infatti
qualche anno dopo Papa Gregorio non lo è
a pezzi cioè quell'uomo non è un uomo è
un demone è un nome né un empia e un
Mefisto da ardere Non si può nemmeno
gioire del recupero delle terre sante
perché l'imperatore stesso le ha
macchiate a riconquistandole ma senza
versare una sola goccia di sangue pagano
solo mediante trattate di pace e intanto
versi poetici infangano le strade sicure
campane e delle Puglie e che giorno come
campane macchiano infide anime e tuniche
alle Corti del pu era Puglie che ignora
così lievemente la scure delle sue due
scomuniche scrive versi d'amore
l'imperatore scrive versi d'amore
l'imperatore fonda scuole poetiche fonda
scuola e l'imperatore può nelle basi
della lingua italiana della lingua di
Dante delle nostre parole l'imperatore
scrive versi d'amore e di Falchi perché
gli animi che ammira sono tutti affamati
sono tutti affamati sono tutti affamati
di voglia di vivere e fuggo Caronte sono
tutti affamati sono tutti affamati sono
tutti affamati come i Rapaci con cui
dalla caccia con me le lepri quanto
riguarda l'ottava Torre di Castel del
Monte la vita nel
1250 è piatta il mondo ha visto troppo
anche la fiamma del sultano battezzato
traballa quasi non è più un fuoco
l'amore per Bianca Lancia ancora lo
anima ma non mi porta più a caccia il
suo trono è rotto il suo tono si è fatto
Rocco sotto un fiore il mago Michele
scoto aveva previsto sarebbe finito lui
non andrà mai a Firenze per questo
motivo ma effettivamente sotto uno
stemma guardato e Fiorito in Puglia a
Castelfiorentino si è spento
l'imperatore Federico il sole è
un'incudine d'oro e tutto è schiacciato
è trafitto Non scrive più versi d'amore
l'imperatore che ho sempre servito il
sole del mondo riposa in un sarcofago
rosso granito nella Palermo gloriosa che
ama di cui fu figlio e che ancora
splende di luce araba di voce Normanna
del canto libero del re bambino cantato
da un falco
nel cielo limpido
grazie Io vorrei salutarvi dato che
abbiamo citato questi giovani che
abbandonano le proprie terre e
soprattutto questo senso di vertigine
che adesso mi anima che è diverso da
quello di un tempo ma che comunque sento
pervasivo raccontandovi che io non abito
più a Bari Io adesso abito a Roma Mi
sono spostato lì per lavoro e
si parla molto di questi Cervelli in
Fuga questo termine molto abusato e si
parla molto raccontando molto delle loro
storie anche quando non si conoscono
bene e soprattutto si parla molto senza
sempre tenere conto del background
Dietro ogni decisione Io credo che delle
volte sia più importante rimanere un sei
molto in silenzio ad ascoltare capire
quelle che sono le motivazioni dietro
una storia sì a volte si racconta di
queste storie di coraggio perché va via
a volte di queste storie di codardia
tutti hanno un'opinione tranne magari
dare Poi voce alle persone che hanno
veramente dovuto prendere una decisione
del genere io vi dico soltanto il mio
punto di vista in questo momento storico
Io penso che se noi non dovessimo
andarcene per cercare vita altrove
Beh allora le strade della mia città non
sarebbero fiumi in secca ma ancora Flori
deriva di tuffi e di giochi gonfie di
canti e di fuochi di gioie di speranze
di suoni e di Ti ricordi quando e di Ma
ci pensi a voi
quelle strade sarebbero ancora
accarezzate dalla brezza leggera degli
Ulivi ma non porterebbe con sé i rovi
dei rimpianti dei rimorsi dei rumori dei
tuoi futuri possibili che oggi non vedi
se non porti il cuore dentro nuovi
luoghi e le suole sopra suole nuove se
non dovessimo andarcene per cercare vita
altrove non conosceremo l'arte della
mimesi era sacro zender cambiare accento
il mandala dei flixbus prese il Daimoku
del pranzare un orario diverso La sacra
disciplina di sentire il cielo sorretto
dalle punte dei palazzi di cemento senza
dare di matto io sono cresciuto abituato
a vederlo quel cielo come un mare nero
profondo e calmo sull'orlo della
campagna dove i grilli sussurrano al
silenzio
se non dovessimo andarcene per cercare
vita altrove non conosceremmo
l'ospitalità del viaggiatore ed il
rispetto del cammino che ogni uomo ha
dentro e non sapremmo che vuol dire
contare le ore e le coincidenze e i
cambi di metro e non conosceremo il
senso di colpa di quando ti scordi di
chiamare nonna di quando sogni di
tornare indietro di quando ricordi che
hai nelle ossa il sangue di un impero
immenso che ancora affiora come una
pallina ombra di vetro dalla suola di
uno stivale che affonda quando ricordi
che tu lo stai abbandonando per metterti
in salvo su una chiatta di un metro
bagnata da un'acqua più sporca se non
dovessimo andarcene per cercare vita
altro il coraggio che abbiamo perso in
viaggio sulle autostrade via supinari
vecchi e consunti mono corsia su cui
ancora muoriamo mentre cerchiamo
un'altra Italia in un altitalia che non
esiste siamo di tarantolati i
colonizzati gli emigrati i bastardi
Briganti meticci i francesi gli iberici
turchi Normanni germanici gli arabi
greci e i Fenici anche se c'è chi di una
bandiera a strisce scorda il verde dei
nostri boschi e insegue quello di leghe
finte scorda il bianco dei Calanchi
addosso insegue quello di razze estinte
scorda il rosso dei nostri Orti e ammira
il rosso nel sangue degli occhi di chi
finge di amare un Sud che per anni ha
chiamato [__] e che prenderebbe
ancora oggi a Calci sul naso come Sfinge
Ah sì i sotterrone Io sono terrore e un
giorno troveremo il coraggio di prendere
il timone la leva del cambio di fare il
randagio al vagone motore e cambiare
equipaggio e direzione e non è un sogno
è il sogno ed è un incrocio tra una
promessa una minaccia ed un bisogno oggi
riparto Ma io un giorno ritorno
Grazie Giuliano vi avevo detto che
sarebbe stato qualcosa di speciale e lo
è stato lo percepito nei volti
nell'attenzione anche nell'emozione di
tutti voi